Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous.
Aujourd’hui, je vais vous inviter à vous
ramener à votre condition d’être vivant,
dans toute sa simplicité,
qui absorbe des éléments,
qui les digère pour grandir
ou simplement pour sa survie,
et qui les excrète.
Pour parler plus trivialement,
on va parler pipi caca.
Je vais essayer de vous convaincre
que si la gestion actuelle du pipi caca
est un peu la cause de notre perte,
ça peut être l’arme pour notre salut.
Démarrons par l’alimentation.
Depuis la révolution verte,
on importe des engrais
parce que les sols ont perdu
énormément en fertilité en France.
On importe principalement trois éléments
qui sont l’azote, le phosphore
et le potassium.
On va démarrer par le cycle de l’azote.
Depuis 1945,
on a trouvé un processus qui permet
de transformer l’azote de l’air
en azote solide,
qu’on appelle les ammonitrates.
Seulement, ça demande énormément
d’énergie, particulièrement du gaz,
donc on fait ça plutôt
dans les pays extracteurs de gaz,
notamment dans le Golfe.
Pour produire une tonne d’ammonitrates, on
a besoin d’une tonne d’équivalent pétrole.
On les rapporte en France,
on les répand sur le sol -
à peu près 30 kg d’azote par personne.
Ce qui va arriver en nourriture
par personne dans les foyers,
c’est à peu près 7 kg -
une énorme perte en ligne.
Il y a des gens qui se sont amusés
à faire une comptabilité azotée
à l’intérieur de la maison
pour savoir ce qui rentre et ce qui sort.
On a souvent l’impression
qu’en faisant notre petit compost
sur le balcon ou dans le jardin,
on a fermé le cycle
des matières organiques.
En fait, on a travaillé seulement
sur entre 20% et un quart
de l’azote entré dans la maison.
Les trois-quarts partent malheureusement
quand on tire la chasse, dans notre pipi.
Ça va dans le réseau d’égouts,
ça va avec des grands tuyaux,
des stations de relevage,
ça arrive à une station d’épuration
qui va faire le processus inverse
mais en dépensant
autant d’énergie qu’au départ.
Elle va transformer
cet azote qui était solide,
qui était potentiellement
utilisable comme engrais,
depuis le liquide - l’urine -
elle va le transformer en azote de l’air.
C’est vraiment dommage
parce qu’on a perdu en entrée
en dépensant énormément d’énergie,
en transformant l’azote de gaz à solide,
et dans la station d’épuration, on en perd
en le changeant de solide à gaz.
En plus, la station d’épuration
ne le fait pas très bien :
les rendements, c’est 60%.
Une énorme quantité d’engrais
part dans les rivières
et crée un phénomène d’eutrophisation,
l’asphyxie des cours d’eau par un
développement d’algues trop important.
C’était le cycle de l’azote, mais il y
en a un encore plus problématique,
c’est le cycle du phosphore.
Le phosphore est une ressource
non renouvelable
qui est très inégalement
répartie dans le monde
puisque 80% des réserves mondiales
sont situées au Maroc.
Comme c’est une ressource non
renouvelable, elle va vers son épuisement.
On annonce son pic
dans deux ou trois décennies,
c’est-à-dire qu’on va arriver assez
rapidement, dans moins de 20 ans,
à une situation où l’offre ne va pas
pouvoir subvenir à la demande.
Là, on voit bien les conflits
que ça peut produire.
C’est sûr que, dans 20 ans,
ça va être une vraie problématique de
nourrir 7 milliards d’habitants ou plus.
Sur les engrais,
la France est dépendante
à 100 % des importations.
Nos sols ont perdu en fertilité
donc on n’arrive pas à se débrouiller,
il faudrait vraiment remettre
de la circularité
parce que notre système d’alimentation et
d’excrétion, il est complètement linéaire
et vraiment problématique.
En plus de ça, si on rajoute
la thématique de l’eau,
on est en zone très très rouge
sur la Méditerranée
avec des prospectives qui annoncent
que le débit des cours d’eau
va être réduit de 50% d’ici 30 ans.
En gros,
on va mourir de soif, il n’y aura
plus d’engrais donc plus à manger.
Vous me direz : « Si on n’a plus à manger,
du coup, on va faire moins caca,
donc on va moins tirer la chasse,
donc il y aura moins d’eau,
peut-être qu’on va s’en sortir comme ça. »
Nous, on a eu très peur
quand on a appris tout ça
et on s’est dit :
« Ne peut-on pas pallier ces problèmes
avec des toilettes sèches ?
Et donc Ecosec est là pour vous sauver. »
Je vous parlais d’humilité au début.
On est arrivés pleins d’espoir
et on s’est dit :
« On va sortir ce pitch-là à tous nos élus
et ils vont installer des cabines de
toilettes publiques dans toute la ville,
ils vont imposer des réseaux en séparatif
dans toutes les nouvelles constructions
pour qu’on puisse recycler les urines,
on va mettre une ceinture
maraîchère autour de la ville,
les maraîchers vont amener des aliments
à l’intérieur de la ville,
et avec le même moyen de transport,
remporter les urines,
et la ville sera complètement
résiliente et indépendante,
on n’aura plus de problème,
et tout sera circulaire. »
Quand on leur a sorti tout ça, on a
vérifié un principe posé par Einstein :
« Il est beaucoup plus difficile
de craquer un préjugé qu’un atome. »
On est allé voir les élus en question
qui nous ont dit : « On est deuxième
au classement de Shanghai,
donc avec vos toilettes « sèches »,
vous devriez aller sur le Larzac.
Là-bas, vous aurez peut-être
plus de clients. »
On s’est dit assez vite :
« Il va falloir casser cet imaginaire
sur la toilette sèche,
car leur faire peur et leur dire qu’on
va tous mourir ne va pas suffire. »
Donc on a fait des toilettes, on a bossé
pour faire des toilettes connectées
Il y avait une application pour calculer
le taux d’urine qu’on collectait ;
on avait un écran LED qui nous disait
la quantité d’eau économisée,
des trônes rétro-éclairés ; on gravait
le nom du client sur la porte ;
on a fait tout ça.
On est passés par la fenêtre parce que les
premiers qui nous ont pris nous ont dit :
« Vous êtes mignons avec vos histoires
d’écologie mais mon problème numéro un,
c’est l’absence de réseau,
donc sont-elles déconnectées ? »
On a dit : « Oui, et elles marchent
en panneaux solaires. »
C’est sur cette fenêtre-là
qu’on est rentrés en premier.
C’est peut-être un trick que je donne
à tous ceux qui se lancent dans l’écologie
en pensant que leur argument
fondamental sera de faire peur :
« Ça ne marche pas. »
Là-dessus, on a tiré la pelote.
Je reviens à ce qui se passe
dans la maison.
C’est assez intéressant le tout à l’égout.
J’aimerais le comparer
à notre vision des déchets solides.
Tout le monde comprend
que si on trie à la source le plastique,
l’aluminium, le fermentescible
et les différents déchets ou le verre,
ça fait des filières beaucoup plus faciles
sur le recyclage et la valorisation.
C’est pareil sur les cycles
liquides dans la maison.
Qu’est-ce que c’est dommage
de gâcher toutes les eaux
grises qu’on consomme.
Un Montpelliérain consomme
145 litres d’eau potable par jour.
Cette eau potable représente
50 mètres cubes à l’année,
qui vont être pourris avec quoi ?
Seulement 20 litres de matières fécales.
Une fois desséché, un humain
ne produit que 20 litres.
C’est dans ces matières fécales
que vont être concentrés les pathogènes.
Ce n’est même pas intéressant
au niveau agronomique.
Le corps a été super intelligent :
il a séparé les urines
et les matières fécales.
Dans les urines, 80% des engrais
peuvent être réutilisés,
et, en plus, c’est stérile.
J’en entends me dire :
« Mon mari pisse au fond du jardin,
ça crame toute l’herbe. »
C’est le même principe qu’en médecine :
entre remède et poison,
ce n’est qu’une question de dosage.
Donc il faut bien doser.
A côté de ça, il y a une problématique
sur les résidus pharmaceutiques.
Aujourd’hui, aucune station d’épuration
ne traite les résidus pharmaceutiques,
donc ça arrive dans les rivières.
Je reviens à mon cycle de la maison.
Ce serait bien de garder cette eau grise
quand on prend une douche de 70 litres.
Dommage de la pourrir
avec des matières fécales,
alors qu’il n’y a qu’un peu
de savon et des poils.
On pourrait tout à fait l’utiliser
pour faire du végétal en ville.
Je vous ramène à toute la
campagne des municipales.
Dans toutes les villes,
lors des canicules, on dit :
« Il faut végétaliser,
ça va rafraîchir la ville. »
Le problème, c’est que Montpellier est,
comme dans toute la Méditerranée,
en zone rouge sur l’eau.
La ville est dépendante
pendant quatre mois
des importations d’eau
qui viennent du bas Rhône.
S’il n’y avait pas l’eau du bas Rhône,
on n’aurait ni d’eau dans le Lez,
ni d’eau dans nos robinets.
Qu’est-ce que c’est dommage de gâcher
toute cette quantité d’eaux grises
qui pourrait être réutilisée
pour faire de la nature.
La nature a un phénomène qui
est aussi utilisé par le corps humain :
l’évaporation de l’eau.
On crée du frais quand on sue.
C’est la transformation de l’état liquide
à l’état gazeux qui va créer du frais.
Nous, on aimerait bien proposer
à toutes les villes
de les refroidir lors des épisodes
caniculaires avec des murs végétaux.
On a calculé qu’on arrive à refroidir
un bâtiment entre 10 et 15 degrés
avec des murs végétaux irrigués juste
avec l’eau de nos douches et les urines.
Quand on va voir un promoteur,
cet argument nous fait
passer par la fenêtre,
il est plus impactant
que l’argument écologique.
Juste lui dire : « Vous vous rendez
compte des économies de climatisation
en plus des bienfaits
d’un bâtiment vert. »
Aujourd’hui, on est sept employés ; on est
en SCOP ; on est entreprise d’insertion.
On essaie de se déployer,
on a mis nos trois premières cabines
dans le centre de Paris.
Des gens en insertion
viennent à vélo les nettoyer -
pas de nettoyage automatique.
Demain, on va faire un premier
bâtiment à Dol-de-Bretagne
de 34 logements entièrement séparatifs.
On espère que, petit à petit,
la pelote va se tirer
qu’on va développer ces technologies,
qu’on va pouvoir récupérer cette eau,
en plus de cette quantité d’urine,
et pouvoir tous vous sauver
d’une mort certaine.
Merci de votre attention.